you say cyrus est bien loin ce coup de
fil vous avez comme tout le monde un
besoin de reconnaissance
et pour ça vous allez devoir vous
confronter à l'autre mais est-ce que
vous êtes sûr de gagner cette
confrontation
pour répondre à cette question et
comprendre un peu mieux ce que je
raconte on va parler de la télé ctic du
maître et de l'esclave beagle georges
guillem friedrich hegel est un
philosophe allemand du 19e siècle et non
je ne ferai pas de blagues sur son nom
de famille perte de gain sa philosophie
est très riche et très complète il fait
partie de ceux qui ont voulu unifier
tout le savoir de leur temps en un vrai
système philosophique où tous les
éléments sont interdépendants un peu à
la aristote ou à l'atome à dakar il ya
un élément qui est très important dans
son oeuvre c'est la dialectique
hégélienne pour comprendre ce qu'est la
télé ctic prenons les stades d'un
pokémon
ici le stade salamèche le stade reste un
sel et l'évolution du stade salamèche
donc quand vous obtenez le stade rennais
celle vous n'avez plus votre staff
salamèche raid parcelles et la fin de sa
la mèche dans les deux sens du terme
c'est à dire que c'est un peu comme un
but une finalité et en même temps ça la
mèche n'existe plus vraiment qu'en
réponse elle arrive c'est sa fin c'est
pareil qu'en rêve d'un celles évoluant
dracaufeu en fait pendant une évolution
on a trois choses une négation dracaufeu
de supprimer recèle une conservation des
princes elle continue d'en dracaufeu en
termes d' adn daou de souvenirs par
exemple et un dépassement dracaufeu sa
1re est un sel dépassé et ce processus
là s'appelle offenburg pas en allemand
pour la péter ou quoi c'est juste qu'on
n'a pas l'équivalent en fait en français
alors on pourrait parler d'humour relève
peut-être en tout cas ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que c'est la signature de
cette dialectique
c'est le même processus pour les plantes
philo qui vont thèse antithèse synthèse
et gueule c'est un ouf avec ça tout
autour de la directive il ya trois
grandes parties dans sa philosophie dans
chacune des parties il ya 3 heures et
dans ses livres il ya trois parties et
dans chaque partie est affreux chapitre
et c est que ça fait une heure qu'on
attend
c'est qu'un très plat ou plat dessert
moi j'avais un très plats et desserts au
facebook prend une pizza quatre fromages
n'ont pas enlevé un cas la raison d'état
sinon on ne fera jamais se plaindre
alors effectivement vous avez bien trois
coups lien alors vous allez voir c'est
un petit peu plus corsé que d'habitude
n'hésitez pas à abuser du bouton pause 1
pouces vous êtes un spectateur actif de
la vidéo ok donc chez égales entre deux
stades d'une dialectique il ya des
relations de négation donc il ya
toujours des relations entre les opposer
d'où cette citation on ne se pose qu'en
s'opposant on se pose dans le sens on se
définir les choses se détermine par
négation être soi c'est aussi être ce
que l'on n'est pas ou ce que l'on n'est
plus ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que si on était dans un principe
d'identité
c'est à dire que si on n'avait pas de
contraire en nous et qu'on avait tout le
temps genre à égal à eybens ne se
passerait rien n'y aurait jamais de
changement à jamais nos mouvements et
donc si on se définit par négation
lemoine n'a de sens qu'en tant qu'il
n'est pas autrui et ça c'est super
intéressant par rapport à une conscience
de soi parce que c'est peut-être que
pour eagle l'existence d'autrui est
indispensable à la conscience de soi
je ne prends conscience de moi que par
la prise de conscience de l'autre et lui
va encore plus loin parce que pour lui
la connaissance de soi passe par la
reconnaissance de soi par l'autre
bonjour comment vous vous appelez alors
je ne m'appelle pas adolf alban
alexander albrecht
ramdin vector voldemort ou les banques
alors on avait trouvé quel prénom et
manque pour nous faire un peu mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe également
utiliser une métaphore est la métaphore
du maître et de l'esclave
alors on parle pas vraiment de deux
individus mais plus de de conscience
quand les deux se rencontrent les deux
ont ce désir de reconnaissance français
un désir qui nous distingue de l'animal
et qu'on a tous plus ou moins forts et
les deux vont essayer d'avoir la
reconnaissance de l'autre mais ce qu'il
faut comprendre ce que pour eagle il
peut pas y avoir d'égalité
du coup il va y avoir une lutte entre
les deux consciences et s'il n'ya pas de
lutte c'est que les deux personnes
n'existe pas encore l'une pour l'autre
elle ne cherche pas encore la
reconnaissance de l'autre ces genres de
personnes qui se croisent dans la rue
voilà donc là par exemple je crois c'est
quelqu'un qui s'en prendre totalement de
ma gueule je n'existe pas pour cette
personne [ __ ] du coup y'a moyen de
gagner un abonné peut-être excusez moi
quand il ya lutte les deux sujets vont
essayer de sa servir vin et l'autre
c'est-à-dire de nier la conscience de
l'autre dans un combat à mort mais sans
tuer l'autre parce que sinon la
conscience qui reste n'est reconnu par
personne et d'ailleurs quand eagle dix
combats à mort c'est une façon de
pareilles le but c'est la neutralisation
de l'autre en tant que rivale il se met
d'un fort et eagle imagine une première
conscience la conscience un qui va
risquer sa vie
c'est à dire qu'elle va risquer de ne
pas être reconnue elle va affirmé son
désir de reconnaissance
jusqu'au bout elle a faim quoi et une
autre conscience qui refusent de la
risqué qui veut juste vivre sa life de
son côté et qui n'a pas un désir très
fort la conscience un seul autre maître
de la conscience de jouer dans une
situation de domination
c'est le maître et l'esclave c'est la
première étape de la dialectique et en
gros c'est le stade salamèche sauf que
le truc c'est que maintenant l'esclave
travail comme un ouf pour le m il fait
des choses il travaillait la nature
alors que le maître lui il est
complètement dépendant de l'esclave et
en plus il est reconnu par quelqu'un qui
ne reconnaît même pas la conscience de
ceux montre mettre de la vie par son
travail
la conscience 1 se montre dépendante de
la conscience de donc la conscience
insérant du esclaves de l'esclave il ya
une inversion
c'est la seconde étape de la télé ctic
angoissé le stable réponse elle donc au
final on a un esclave qui est devenu
maître et un maître qui est donné ce
clap et de conscience réalisent ensemble
que domination les servitudes ne sont
pas enviables
chacun a eu sa reconnaissance il ya donc
une annulation de la relation maître
esclave c'est la dernière étape de la
télé qnx est donc le stade dracaufeu et
levures beaucoup d'enfants alors il est
poussé que cette dialectique du maître
et l'est
on vous rappelle plusieurs choses parce
qu'on peut la transposer à plein de
trucs par exemple des relations
professeurs élèves enfants parents les
relations de couple employeurs salariés
et même ça nous rappelle la lutte des
classes de marx et c'est normal parce
que cette dialectique a eu une grande
influence sur le maintenant en attendant
qu'on passe au stade de 2,7 électique je
reste votre serviteur j'ai besoin de
reconnaissance
donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
partager cette vidéo on se retrouve dans
deux semaines jeudi 18h vous envoie du
love et de la pisse au cul ouais ça un
coup fil avec un niveau un peu plus
élevé que les autres un petit peu à la
quand wall and each ne vous inquiétez
pas le prochain sera beaucoup plus
légère donc comme je vous dis la
prochaine vidéo sera dans deux semaines
je faisais 18 heures j'essaie de faire
un rendez-vous toutes les deux semaines
et j'ai pas dû oublier de vous faire une
vidéo pour vous remercier d'être sans
billet c'est juste que je la ferai à un
moment où j'ai d'autres gars vous
annoncer donc voila vous inquiétez
n'était pas à me suivre sur facebook et
sur twitter je balance le truc différent
à chaque fois sur les deux offres
exclusives et sur ce match à tous et où
je peux raconter ma vie ou ont partagé
des trucs faire des fils tendus ce que
je vois en voilà n'hésitez pas c'était
une grosse bise ou art non je ne suis
pas le père noël